this is actually a little paper
calculator that i made you follow a tube
they split off these tubes are
directional
your first choice is whether you want to
choose zero or one which would you like
to choose let's choose zero zero so you
choose zero that leads to this uh this
instruction to flip
you flip the page
continue down plus you don't choose the
operator
but you do choose the next number that
you want to add to zero one let's do
zero plus one zero plus one
go here
then you just follow the tubes this is
all done automatically
you follow down
down
zero plus one is one that's your answer
zero one is the answer
let's do zero plus zero zero plus zero
okay
so you start here you choose zero
this tells you to flip
so there's your zero
let's choose to add another zero so
we'll flip again
so you'll notice when you flip these
flaps they can either connect or block
off certain pathways
later on
so that's basically how it all works
you follow
these paths
when you get to here it says to flip
and then you get to the end so
your answer is zero zero all right let's
do one plus one jason okay i've always
wanted to know what that is it's a good
thing i have this calculator here
i'll go ahead and choose this one
leads me to one
i'll add another one
that goes to the equal sign
it tells me to flip
tells me to flip again
and there's our answer uh 1 0 or a two
in binary this is basically how
calculators and computers work um you
know elec electronic versions of these
mazes
if you'd like to know why on earth jason
was making a calculator out of paper you
really need to see what came before and
what's coming next have a look at these
extra videos that we're putting on
number file either right now or very
soon
you